let's build a perfect Ro receiver who
got the best hands in the league right
now who should we put ah yeah Devonte
Adams for hands who we go be Tar Hill or
jayen W them boys are fast man TG kill
for Speed route running stuff on this
got some clean route running my D ad got
some clean route running too we going
digs man Stu onun digs for Route Running
Man blocking definitely going DK matf no
Bron a bron a bron
blur who we head type of stuff man yeah
Jamar Chase he is going to blur some 90%
of the time AJ Brown do to though
pickings yeah George pickings for blur
and drip Debo SIM for drip man AJ Brown
do be having drip too but Debo be
putting that stuff
on